the SEC has been hostile to crypto ever
since well really under Clayton and now
of course under Gensler
that hostility is nothing new so it's
not entirely surprising that they're
going after cracking and staking I would
say the intensification is evident from
the SEC in terms of oversight I believe
that they feel emboldened that they have
more of a political mandate now to go
after crypto post 2022 in the FTX
collapse so I think the same
undercurrent Trends are driving the
sec's action and the action of the FED
FDIC OCC which is feeling politically
emboldened due to a lot of people are
sympathetic with attempts to ring funds
through crypto space in the US after the
collapses of last year and also Congress
being deadlocked that's an important
thing that I think people are not
talking about is the prospects for
legislation here of any sort are very
minimal going forwards for the next two
years
I don't think we'll see anything
pertaining to crypto actually believe it
or not even though the house is somewhat
favorable so the agencies realize
nothing's going to come out of Congress
nothing's going to be done that way
they're going to be stymied let's say
the Biden administration at a crypto
crypto package they wanted to push it
they wouldn't be able to do that for the
house so now a lot of folks in the
executive branch are saying to
themselves while it's on us to regulate
effectively legislate through regulation
and that is absolutely what we're seeing
at the SEC they are interpreting their
mandate in a very broad way as is the
fed the FED is now growing their mandate
there's a little there's some wonkish
details in the January 27 chain of
events which I mean are probably worth
digging into but yeah I think that's
what we're seeing really is there's an
understanding in Washington now Congress
is deadlocked okay it's on us The
Regulators to do something can I ask
um you know when with something like FTX
clearly you know kind of the crypto
winter kind of sets the stage for more
regulation because you have a lot of
people who are probably going you know
either grousing to their Congressman or
you know there's a sense like okay you
know we lost this huge percentage of
whatever we had invested in crypto for
whatever reason and we're kind of pissed
about that uh this you know happened uh
you know after the uh the tech Bubble
Burst you know there's new stock market
stuff as a housing bubble bursts you
know there's new regulations
um with FTX
um really puts gas on all of that can I
ask you was is there something the
crypto Community should have been doing
to kind of unmask or expose or pull get
people to stop putting money into FTX
ahead of time or is there anything like
that is there you know what if if
broadly speaking crypto is going to be
something that is independent of
government and independent of Regulation
not not independent of risk but like is
there something that people in the
crypto space should have or could have
been doing more of to unmasked like to
squeeze out the the sbfs of the world
before they get to a point where they
really threaten everybody Who's acting
you know in a positive way absolutely
without a doubt there's three things
specifically one is the investors need
to be better with their diligence quite
today a lawsuit dropped against Sequoia
and Paradigm the lead investors in that
FTX deal alleging that they failed in
their diligence and in fact they sort of
endorsed FTX and caused people to trust
it wrongly I'm sympathetic to that
frankly I'm a VC we didn't invest in FTX
because they were an offshore brokerage
we looked at the early rounds I have
those pitch decks yeah because they're
an offshore brokerage we thought there
was no way they could come onshore
legally they had the ftt token which we
thought was an unregistered security
which would cause them problems down the
road and they had Alameda trading on the
exchange I was looking back at my old
email trail from LPS why didn't you
invest in FDX you got the look what are
you doing you missed this huge deal we
told them exactly that there's no way in
exchange in the US would be able to have
a proprietary trading firm owned by the
same entity trading exclusively on the
exchange that would not be allowed and I
guess it's worth hammering home the fact
that you know FTX was was exposed at a
moment when a company that was going
thinking about buying it said ah you
know what we're not going to do this
because we don't trust it I mean the
market on some profound level the market
worked to expose a bad company but so
like what do you think what do you think
happened there because you know there's
presumably some pretty smart people at
Sequoia and these other big investors
why did they miss what you were seeing
pretty clearly
different approach to risk tolerance
um and also
um they the deal Dynamics I mean in 2021
remember hottest time Venture Capital
history I'm sure the deal was moving
extremely fast this was the fastest
growing company in the industry in the
hottest industry on Earth for Venture
dollars so the power would have been
totally on the side of the founders and
not on the side of the VC so I'm sure
they understood they needed to do less
diligence this will come out in the
court of law eventually what happened in
order to win the deal and they thought
that that was a worthwhile trade-off I
mean it wasn't just FTX where this was
the mindset among VCS it was very common
back then
you you know you you mentioned sorry
could you also you you had said there
were three things that
um the crypto uh world could be doing
and just to get back to this one of them
was doing due diligence like investors
doing due diligence do you remember the
other two uh yeah so for just to
summarize the first thing VCS aren't
just VCS their stakeholders aren't just
their LPS they're stakeholders are
everyone and when you're investing in
these exchanges that have hundreds of
millions of clients globally your
stakeholders everyone that uses crypto
because if you fail you'll bring the
regulatory hammer down which is what is
happening now so VCS need to understand
that
um two proof of reserves it's a very
obvious thing
if there had been approved reserves in
place which is basically a procedure
whereby an exchange or custodian
demonstrates that they have reserves and
then they compare those to their client
liabilities and they show they match
that's cryptographically provable it's
technically very doable quite a few
exchanges do it already
if FTX had done that obviously they
wouldn't have been able to commit fraud
if proof of reserves had been normalized
throughout the industry FTX wouldn't
have been able to do it assuming they
were in this parallel universe they were
doing fraud and they would have been
sticking out like a sore thumb so if
that was normalized throughout the
industry
these insolvencencies FTX Mount Cox
quadriga they would be really evident so
that is a very simple thing I'm pushing
very hard for it you'll actually see
legislation Texas introduced a bill
asking for it I think that'll pass
that'll become part of the
self-regulatory framework that is used
in the industry and it's a very positive
thing unfortunately we're too late now
and the only reason it's got so much
uptake is because of FTX
the third thing is just building better
decentralized exchanges such that we
don't have a Reliance on centralized
exchanges that's also happening so the
technological Trends here are very
self-regulatory as far as I can tell hey
thanks for watching that excerpt from
our live conversation with SEC
commissioner Hester purse and crypto
investor and writer Nick Carter about
the government's escalating Crackdown on
cryptocurrency exchanges like Kraken and
the broader defy economy join me and
nicolespie here every Thursday at 1 pm
Eastern for more conversations like this
and subscribe to recent's YouTube
channel for notifications whenever our
videos go live
thanks for watching